Greetings, brave adventurers!
Seekers of knowledge, explorers of the great
unknown!
No doubt by now you have heard the stories
of the noble Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood,
gentleman explorer and naturalist, also known
as SCP-1867.
His exploits are known far and wide, though
some question the validity of his tales, due
to the simple fact that he is a neon sea slug
and not a human man.
Bah!
These are, of course, fools!
A gentleman never lies about his grand escapades!
We have even covered Lord Blackwood before,
in “A Sea Snail's Fantasy SCP-1867 - A Gentleman,”
but never before have we taken a look at such
a daring account of his work.
Today we discuss a most curious hunting expedition,
one that brought our Lord Blackwood face to
face with the great beast, the hard-to-destroy
reptile, SCP-682 itself!
What will become of our hero?
What sights will he see on his journey?
Let us find out.
Tally-ho!
On May 14, 1883, months after nearly losing
his life while climbing Mt.
Everest, Lord Blackwood received a letter
at his London home.
Upon opening it, he saw that it was a formal
invitation from one Colonel Joseph D’Enfante,
of the French Army.
It invited him to participate in a hunt for
a monster known as The Tarasque, that threatened
the lives and security of the French people.
Anyone who was able to slay the creature would
receive a handsome award of five million pounds
for their trouble.
Unable to resist a challenge, the chance to
face off against a creature he had never heard
of before, or the allure of such an impressive
prize, Lord Blackwood sent off an acceptance.
So what was the Tarasque?
Lord Blackwood’s research turned up a fearsome
description: it was a massive scaly creature
with a hide that seemed impossible to pierce,
that breathed fire and killed everything in
its path without batting an eye.
A worthy foe indeed.
By the end of the day, Lord Blackwood had
received an address where he would attend
a briefing before the hunt would commence.
The meeting was held at a private room in
the city, in an exclusive club.
There were three other would-be hunters there,
Mr. Roosevelt from America, Mr. Dukov, from
Russia, and Mr. Harris, from England.
The Colonel greeted the men, and told them
what they were up against.
A beast had lain waste to a French town, ripping
men, women, and children to shreds and resisting
every blow dealt against it by the army.
So, the Colonel vowed to gather expert scientists
and hunters, for if they could not take down
the monster, it was likely that no one could.
On May 20th, the party arrived in France to
begin the great adventure.
Each man brought his own armaments, a combination
of specialized weapons and knowledge, for
the task at hand.
The following day, the Colonel escorted the
men to the quarantine zone, where the beast’s
attack had led it.
Lord Blackwood was troubled by the sights
there, it was a city at war.
Soldiers patrolled the streets, and barricades
were placed at the edge of town.
Citizens were being evacuated as soldiers
aided them, and few had seen the beast themselves.
At least, they had not been unfortunate enough
to see it up close.
Beyond the quarantine barrier, it was hell
on earth.
There were bodies laying in the streets, buildings
burnt to the ground, castles and stone walls
reduced to piles of rubble.
There was not one living thing in sight, not
a person, a farm animal, or even so much as
an insect.
The men set up camp near the edge of the town,
and Mr. Harris set about tracking the beast.
Before too long, he had found it, to the southwest,
and the next day they would set off after
it.
The next day, the party made its way southwest
to Belleville, following a trail of destruction.
There, they found it having a nap in the sun.
It was longer than a whale, taller than a
giraffe, and bigger than both.
Lord Blackwood thought that, if it had any
visible wings, he would consider it a dragon.
They approached slowly, careful not to wake
the Tarasque.
Lord Blackwood crouched behind a fence, steadied
his gun, and fired right at its head.
The shot hit, and the top of the Tarasque’s
head came off with its impact.
It seemed as if the beast was, after so much
pomp and circumstance, dead right there.
But sadly, it was not.
It sprang to life, blood and brains dripping
from its open skull as it turned to the men
and roared, then charged.
The men scattered, firing their guns as they
ran, the monster gaining on them faster and
faster until Mr. Dukov fired into its open
wound with an electric rifle.
It was stunned long enough for the men to
make it onto their horses.
As they rode away, the monster continued to
chase them, new skin and bone growing over
what had once been a hole in its skull.
Lord Blackwood fired a particle destabilizer
at its leg, tearing it off, but as he watched
in horror…the leg began to grow back.
The hunting party managed to escape with their
lives, though their confidence was thoroughly
shaken.
They rested that night with the soldiers at
the barricade.
They attempted to attack the Tarasque again
the following day, but failed once more.
The men realized that a simple gunshot, electrocution,
or fire would not be enough to kill the monster.
It simply healed too fast, and its tolerance
for pain was too high.
In order to kill it, they realized, they would
have to render it immobile and destroy its
body so thoroughly that it would die before
it could rebuild itself.
And so, they decided to set a trap.
They dug a massive trench, wide and long enough
for the monster, and deep enough that it would
not be able to climb out before they had killed
it.
In the bottom of the pit, they placed hundreds
of steel spikes, the tips dipped in poison.
They placed a bridge across it, strong enough
for the men and horses but weak enough to
break under the Tarasque’s weight, and covered
it all with grass and leaves.
Now, they just had to wait.
Mr. Roosevelt acted as bait, approaching the
monster on horseback and attacking it with
a gunshot, then running and leading it back
toward the trap.
As Roosevelt raced across the bridge, the
creature pursued him, and fell into the pit
where it was impaled on the spikes.
Then, the men rained down hellfire.
They shot it with bullets, explosives, jellied
kerosene.
Mr. Dukov fired a pitchblende-gun that, upon
firing, released a blur of smoke and fire.
Once the fire had receded, all that remained
was a skeleton.
The men took the skull, charred from the flames,
and planned to take it back as a trophy.
All was well!
Or so it seemed…
The men returned to the town with the monster’s
skull in tow, and the soldiers cheered at
the sight.
They posed for photographs, and Mr. Dukov
decided to pose with his head between the
jaws of the beast.
This was a grave mistake on his part, and
the jaws closed tight around his neck, his
head falling to the ground.
The skull acted on its own, rolling and biting,
all the while growing fresh skin and scales.
It opened its gaping maw and shouted: “"Vous
me rendez malade.”
Screams rang out behind Lord Blackwood and
he turned to see…the rest of the Tarasque’s
body, a headless corpse covered with stringy
bits of muscle and slowly growing brand new
flesh.
It stomped through the field, crushing men
and tents beneath its great feet on its way
to reclaim its head.
Mr. Harris ran for the bank vault, to grab
a weapon he had only referred to previously
as “his secret weapon.”
Lord Blackwood chased after him, and found
Harris pulling a large crate, which he opened
with a sense of desperation.
There, inside, was a sarcophagus, bound in
chains and covered in ancient runes.
Blackwood begged Harris to leave the thing
behind and run for his life, but he did not
have a chance to finish before Harris opened
the lid, and an arm wielding a sword emerged
and sliced his head from his body.
A man emerged from the sarcophagus, naked,
wielding a sword, covered in tattoos.
Blackwood had no way of knowing this, but
the man was none other than the deadly warrior
SCP-076, or Able.
The mysterious man attacked Blackwood and
Roosevelt, and though they tried to defend
themselves, no weapon seemed to have an effect
on him.
He was preparing to deliver a final blow to
Blackwood, and kill him once and for all,
when the Tarasque burst through the wall of
the building with a mighty bellow.
At the sight of the enormous monster, Able
turned his focus from the two men to the beast.
And so, the two seemingly unkillable creatures,
driven by bloodlust and inhuman strength,
began to fight.
It took over an hour, and left destruction
and death in its wake.
Able armed himself with explosives, mounting
them to his chest along with the pitchblende
gun, and ran toward the Tarasque.
Knowing what would come next, Roosevelt and
Blackwood locked themselves in the bank vault,
and prayed that someone would find them before
they starved to death.
After two days, the men were saved by a major
of the army, who was leading a group of soldiers
in a search for any survivors.
They were taken to the hospital, and nursed
back to health by the staff there as well
as a friend of Blackwood’s named Henry.
The major who rescued them told them that
Colonel was dead, and so were ten thousand
others claimed by the massive explosion.
The Tarasque and Able had both disappeared,
and there was no indication of where either
of them had gone.
All that was left was destruction and the
memory that a true monster had made itself
known on French soil.
Now, the only thing left to do was recover,
as best as anyone could.
It would certainly take a very long time.
The army was very suspicious of both Roosevelt
and Blackwood, as the only survivors of an
explosion so large it had been seen throughout
France.
They demanded to know how the two had survived,
and what they had seen.
Throughout this process, an Englishman watched
and took notes, but did not speak a word.
Roosevelt and Blackwood were eventually released,
but they did not receive a penny of their
promised reward, and were told they could
not return to France again for the rest of
their lives.
They were not to speak a word of what they
had seen to anyone, or there would be dire
consequences.
In Calais, the two survivors said goodbye,
and Roosevelt announced he would return to
America to pursue a career in politics.
Who can say what happened to him after that?
Upon returning to his home in London, Lord
Blackwood found that he had received a postcard.
It read: “The Royal Foundation for the Security,
Containment, and Protection of Anomalous Objects
and Phantasmagoria requests a meeting for
the purpose of negotiating an alliance favourable
to both our parties.
Please call any time (except Sundays) at No.
19 Marylebone Road, Westminster, and ask to
speak to Doctor Thursday.
Your discretion is requested in this matter.”
He was puzzled by this note, unsure of what
to make of it.
Perhaps, he thought, he could see what they
had to say.
After all, he was always curious and ready
to explore new territory.
Once he had recovered sufficiently, he would
reach out to this strange group and see what
they might have to offer him.
And so began a new chapter of Lord Blackwood’s
story, one that included a mysterious organization
called The SCP Foundation.
Now go check out “A Sea Snail's Fantasy
SCP-1867 - A Gentleman” and “SCP-682 - Ways
SCP Foundation Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy
Reptile” for more about the two anomalies
featured in today’s thrilling tale!